another weekend of chaos with
anti-israel protesters flooding the
streets over a thousand people marching
in Manhattan with one agitator getting
cheered on while tearing down an
American flag others facing off with
police while smashing on doors outside
of Grand Central Station in Delaware a
group marching outside Biden's home
demanding a ceasefire and accusing him
of supporting genocide let's go to
Austin Texas a group of protesters on
horse back waving Palestinian Flags
while taking over the streets vice
president KLA Harris asked to condemn
what we've been seeing instead she said
this people have a right to protest we
are a
democracy and we should value the voices
and listen to the voices what I hope is
that we can engage in conversation and
discourse in a way that understands this
is not binary not to mention what it
means in our own country in terms of
longstanding issues with anti-Semitism
which has been on the rise and even
before before this happened um
islamophobia and and other forms of hate
against people just simply based on who
they are or how they pray it's a lot of
words so she's not the only Democrat
raising eyebrows liberal Bill Maher
berading Barack Obama over the former
president's moral equivalency between
Israel and
Hamas I must say I I am struggling with
people's moral equivalency still I mean
Barack Obama who has rarely disappointed
me did so this week the attack was only
a month ago a more Savage attack than
we've ever seen in Reverse there's a big
difference between collateral damage and
what Hamas did when they fire at Israel
it's a war when Israel fires back it's a
war crime little crazy so and also would
Hamas do that would they give four hour
pause no no
pausing Jesse is there a little bit of
daylight between KLA Harris and Biden
because Biden has been pretty stalwart
in saying Israel needs has the right to
defend himself and I'm just wondering if
there was a little bit of KLA Harris
saying we got to see both sides here
that might be by design that daylight
because they're trying to straddle
supporting Israel and managing the
protest movement so it doesn't hurt them
in the election but I'm with Greg I
might just convert to woke to be able to
protest because if you're a conservative
and you go to a school board meeting and
raise a Ruckus cuz some transgender kid
raped your daughter in a bathroom and
the school covered it up or maybe you
were a tea party protester who didn't
like the Wall Street bailouts or perhaps
you wanted to support election Integrity
or maybe you held a sign at Michigan
State House and said we'd like to go
back to work now Governor if you do that
you get audited you get arrested you get
smeared you probably get put on a no fly
list maybe the Southern Poverty Law
Center cancels your life but you're
saying if you have a massive movement
all over the country for a month where
you're desecrating monuments vandalizing
the White House it's now deadly you
murdered a Jewish guy in Los Angeles
everyone just wants to be cautious let's
just give him room to breathe let's not
do anything you don't get the full
weight of the federal government the
military industrial complex the Democrat
media industrial complex reigning down
on your movement you don't get that and
that's not right and that's not fair and
at this point the American people if
you're conservative it's it's almost
dangerous to get out on the street and
protest but it's not dangerous to get
out in the street and Hoist the
Palestinian flag and tear down the
American flag there's like no arrests
right and Greg where is the White House
urgency about American hostages nowhere
I'm still TR look man I'm still trying
to make heads or Tales of what KLA just
said so she said not binary or
non-binary uh in applying to this she
might be right in that there's only one
way one way to look at what happened
there isn't two ways so maybe that's not
nonbinary it could one binary if it's
non-binary you could say one One
Direction is non-binary because the
people that say there are both sides are
relying on a historical narrative to
justify present day atrocity it's only
about October 7th we don't care about
anything before because that thing is
the worst thing we've seen since 911
maybe if you look at the pictures it
might be worse so it's a mental state
versus the Jewish State and the only way
these anti-sat can Embrace a truly
immoral repulsive Act is by Conjuring up
a context to justify or erase or deny
Terror know Bill Mah is like a load star
for the central liberal Centrist liberal
you know when your party blinks before a
contingent that uses the word but after
saying Hamas behe beheaded babies yeah
yeah yeah but you need to run screaming
from that party uh you cannot March
metaphoric Al or Liberal Liberal uh
literally alongside genocidal deniers uh
it this is not part of the big picture
the only picture is from October 7th it
goes back to this thing you have a
delusional generation of young people
out there so you have to examine how we
lost these people what happened what
happened so what used to education used
to be a social issue but now it's a
security issue you should start worrying
a little bit what are they telling them
right there's anti-west propaganda now
being taught in schools and maybe it's
time to rethink how we look at education
it's not a social thing anymore it's a
security thing this is now about the
future of our country what do we do
judge the Jewish people are 2.6% of the
US population yet suffer 60% of hate
crimes there hate crimes against Jewish
Americans are up 400% since October 7th
and the response from the White House
was a national strategy on islamophobia
yeah yeah uh the amazing part of it is
that and I think that Jesse is right I
think that this Administration is trying
to straddle both issues and I don't
understand it because I think I
mentioned last week that the Arab
American vote Nationwide is like 1% so
um you know this whole idea that you
know we have to you know maybe we need a
two-state solution and with commala says
uh I hope we can have a conversation and
discourse um you know none of these
people who are Marching and prot testing
want a conversation and discourse when
they start you know chanting settlers
settlers go back home Palestine is ours
alone that's not a conversation that's
not a two-state solution or we don't
want a Jewish State we just want back 48
which is when Israel became a nation
state and from The River To The Sea I
mean everybody knows that's for the
elimination of Israel and you know the
the statement that someone made when
they attack Israel it's War but when
Israel defends her self pursuant to the
laws of war it's a war crime and this is
something that has repeated itself
throughout history and now America is
stuck with a group of people not just a
group of people an
incredible um uh chaos a mob of people
who were standing up for Palestine when
Palestine was given the ability to take
over the Gaza and they elected Hamas and
this is one of the consequences and
Israel waited weeks before they started
the assault to let them get out but I
think that that that using a transgender
term Greg I didn't understand it either
when she said nonbinary nonbinary you
know the truth is we've got American
hostages over there we're in the middle
of a war you take a side in a war you
can't strad Jessica tomorrow there is a
anti-Semitism March in DC pro-israel
March in Washington DC I expect it's
going to get a large turnout turnout
enounter imagine if Biden or KLA Harris
actually went to that wow I think it
would be great I have a lot of friends
that are going prob not happening well I
don't think that that's fair I mean as
you said in your opener asking if
there's daylight between Biden and KL on
this I I happen to think that both of
them have been very very clear about
where the US stands on this um Joe Biden
has been more pro-israel than Israelis
expected more than BB Netanyahu expected
more than other world leaders who have
followed him in to this saying you
unequivocally get our support for
everything that you need um I'd love it
if they showed up I don't know if that's
on the docket um but either way I expect
um a wonderful turn out there as it
should be but what kamla Harris is
talking about and she said not binary
first of all in terms of this isn't a
black and white issue everyone who is
marching with the Palestinian flag or
with these people is not necessarily
pramas some of them are actually out
there saying we need to free Palestine I
have issues with the occupation what
goes on or what they perceive as the
occupation in the West Bank now do I
think it's the right time for that
absolutely not because this is all about
as Greg said what happened on October
7th there was a ceasefire that day and
it was violated by one group of
terrorists that did this but 388 per
spike in anti-semitic hate crimes 182%
spike in islamophobic hate crimes that
is also existing within our borders she
is the vice president for all Americans
and I don't I get that people want to
score political points about it but I
don't know how people who are supportive
of Israel and want to make sure that
they can do whatever they need to to
root out Hamas and to avenge the deaths
the 1400 deaths and get those hostages
back could complain about this
Administration and politics is a binary
choice and we saw that on Election night
right that there were Democrats and
Republicans on the ballot and people
picked Democrats and I'm listening to
the front runner on the other side talk
and Donald Trump is not only it's seven
times he's now confused Biden and Obama
which should put him in the uh mental
acuity ouse there right that he can't
find his pants at least like Biden but
this is what the man tweets out what is
this because you're talking about the
leadership that we're seeing and then
we're talking about KLA and Joe she's
the right and I'm saying that all of
this for people is contextualized in
light of Elections and what is on the
other side of this matters to people
that's how there are lots of Jew right
who can't make a decision I I I don't
when I see those marches I don't see
what you see and I'm surpris you look at
it this way because those people don't
like you I have I have I wavered one bit
ever that's not a political that's not a
political statement coming from I'm not
saying oh you got to do this I I don't
I'm not talking about Biden and I'm not
talking about Trump I'm talking about
something bigger that is happening in
this country that puts your life at risk
I understand that and I certainly deeply
feel that but this segment is about
kamla Harris who is an elected official
and who said that I mean but one of the
things I wanted to point out is that
there is a big March tomorrow for
anti-Semitism and it's going to be great
it's going to be huge we will cover it
here on Fox News where you can see it
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else